today I'm building the strongest pirate
crew in one piece I'll go through every
rooll on the ship and pick the best
possible character for that role and at
the very end of the video we'll be left
with the most overpowered crew you've
ever seen the first member every crew
needs is of course a ship as you can't
really be a pirate without one obviously
Roger and the Emperors have the
strongest ships in the series except for
kaido who apparently doesn't even have a
ship now while we don't know of which
material most of the emperor ships were
built of we do know that Roger ship Oro
Jackson is made out of wood from tree
atam a rare tree considered to be the
most durable in the entire world this
alone makes Auto Jackson a good
Contender for the best ship in one piece
but there's actually two more ships that
we need to consider first for example
big mom ship Queen Mama chanter is a
giant ship with many cool features but
it has one problem this ship is heavily
reliant on big mom's abilities so if she
isn't there to power it it would
instantly become much weaker or maybe
even stop working alt together and the
final ship we need to consider is
everyone's favorite th000 sunny as you
already know this is the straw hatch
ship and it's also made from tree
adamswood same as oo Jackson however
besides that it also has some really
cool additions like for example coup the
burst which lets the ship jump away from
danger so between the Auto Jackson and
the Thousand Sunny I think the Thousand
Sunny takes the crown as the strongest
ship in one piece simply because it's
one of the most technologically advanced
ships in the series and was created by
Iceberg and Frankie who are both
Legendary Ships now that we have a ship
we can start assembling our overpowered
crew which will consist of 11 members in
total and for starters we need someone
to Pilot the ship believe it or not
there's only four known helmsmen in the
entire Series so our options for this
role are pretty limited first we have
hakan the Helmsman of the heart Pirates
and same as the majority of This Crew
he's a complete weakling and wouldn't
contribute to our crew in any way next
is Jesus spess the Helmsman of the
Blackbeard Pirates he used to be quite
weak on drosa but has since then
obtained the ri Nomi which granted him
inhuman strength he can now casually
pick up mountains and smash the
Subscribe button harder than anyone else
you probably can't smash it as hard as
him but you're free to try to thanks
anyway despite this there's still two
more contenders for this position who
are likely even stronger than beess the
first one is jinbe the Helmsman of the
straw hat Pirates recently during the
wano arc Jin showed us just how powerful
his fisherman Kara can be which caused
his bounty to rise to over 1 billion
berries now it would be pretty much
impossible to guess who's stronger
between jinbe and Bess is we know very
little about vess's actual strength so I
guess it's a good thing that we don't
actually have to rank them since the
final onepiece Helmsman is so much
stronger than both of them you may
consider this cheating but Shiki of the
golden Lions Pirates is listed to be
both captain and Helmsman of his crew so
I guess it's fair Shiki was one of
Rogers greatest Rivals who commanded the
biggest Fleet on the Seas and after
Roger was captured he went to Marine
Fort and fought against both GARP and
sangoku at the same time okay it's
pretty obvious that Shiki is the
strongest Helmsman in the story but
there's still 10 roles on the ship left
that are much more important than this
one for example when times get rough in
so and Falls ill a doctor is necessary
to make sure everything is fine and we
have a few talented doctors to choose
from firstly we of course have to
mention the straw hats Dr Chopper who's
aiming to become the best doctor in the
world now although his medical skills
and knowledge are among the best in the
series in terms of strength Chopper is
significantly weaker than some of the
other doctors we can choose from another
potential candidate is Doc Q who's got
to be super strong due to all the
overpowered devil fruits Blackbeard
Pirates stole but considering we know
nothing specific about him and his
powers dog Q gets a pass for now this
only leaves us with two possible
candidates law and Marco Marco has
Decades of fighting experience and has
been on whitebeard's Cru since he was a
kid he's shown us Time and Time how
strong he is fighting Admirals on Marine
Ford making a complete joke out of king
and queen and even briefly overwhelming
big mom law on the other hand is one of
the strongest members of the worst
generation and has played a big part in
taking down the previous two Emperors I
think a lot of fans would agree that
Mark was a bit stronger between the two
however law has one thing going for him
his devil fruit obey op noi with it lock
can perform miraculous surgeries and can
save people from pretty much any injury
I don't doubt Marco is also an
incredible doctor but he can't hope to
compete with law here which means that
the official doctor for our crew will be
truffle guard D law and although doctor
is a really important role this next one
is possibly the most important one as
without it the crew can never find the
one piece the archaeologist the job of
archaeologists is to decipher the
poneglyphs and find the location of
laugh taale and due to how hard this is
we're very limited in our choices only a
few pirates in the entire show can do
this one of them is clover who was
revealed to be a pirate before becoming
a scholar on ohata but he's super weak
so we'll have to look for someone else
another one is Charlotte pudding who
should be able to read the poneglyphs
when she awakens her third eye if she
awakens it but until that happens
there's a couple more better candidates
of course one of them is Nico Robin who
can both read the poneglyphs and is also
a capable fighter due to her incredible
devil fruit but although she's a good
candidate there's one person who's just
better at this role in every single way
who Suzuki Odin Odin's insane power in
hockey left a permanent wound on kaido
and even surprised both Whitebeard and
Roger it's also a plus that he already
successfully led the Roger Pirates to
laugh tail once so he's without a doubt
the best character for this position
however adding Odin to the crew creates
a small problem all members are now
close quarter Fighters so in order to
balance it out a bit we need to recruit
a sniper next choosing the best sniper
will be hard but thankfully there's tons
of skilled snipers to choose from
there's some obvious ones like yasa and
Usopp father and son who are both EX
snipers or Charlotte pariso big mom
Zelda son who can use his devil fruit
ability to create sharp candy arrows
however many people also forget how good
of a marksman ISO is he was one of
Whitebeard Pirates strongest members and
played a big role in freeing wano and of
course we have to mention Blackbeard
Pirates van AER who showed us how good
of a sniper he is when we first met him
all the way back on G there he shot down
some birds from at least 10 km away
since then he probably got much stronger
as well due to the devil fruit he ate
wapu wapu no me which lets him teleport
wherever he wants so out of all the
snipers we just mentioned the two who
stand out the most are yasa and Von AER
now I just talked about how insane Von
AER is however I think that yasa might
actually be better than him for one
simple reason he's almost double Von
auger's age which means he's much more
combat experienced and just the fact
that he's one of the main officers of
the redhair Pirates should be enough to
Grant him a place in our crew and you
can't have a functional crew without
someone to fix the ship when it gets
damaged which means we need the ship
right next now this might come as a
surprise to you but shipright is
actually not a standard position on the
ship apparently as only a couple of
Crews have one for example the crew with
the most ship rights are actually the
foxy Pirates but come on let's be real
here do you seriously remember any of
these guys yeah didn't think so some of
the other candidates for the best ship
right are Yu the ship writ of the
black cat Pirates and keso the ship R of
the arlong Pirates and yeah both of
these don't sound like a good option
either there's also stanson a giant from
the auction house on Sal who after
getting back to LF joined the new Giant
Warrior Pirates as a ship right and even
though a giant shipright would be a
pretty cool choice for our crew there's
actually one more ship right who's much
more fitting for the role of course I'm
talking about everyone's favorite
shipright Frankie besides being an
excellent shipright Frankie is also a
really powerful fighter due to his
cyborg body and weapons and even though
it doesn't mean much I have to give
Frankie some credit for blowing a giant
hole through St Saturn which is pretty
badass if you ask me okay this crew is
already pretty amazing but an amazing
crew like this also deserves an amazing
cook to keep them all satisfied however
it can't just be any cook as they also
have to be powerful enough to be
accepted on the ship with these beasts
so is there anyone that would fit the
role for example the one possible
candidate is streusen the cook of the
big mom Pirates He's Surely a really
skilled cook as he was able to guide a
team of chefs to craft an immensely
complicated wedding cake and was also
strong enough to withstand a burst of
big mom's conquer is hockey however a
much better cook than him is obviously
Sanji who can make a delicious meal out
of any ingredient and is also crazy
strong especially after Awakening his
germa abilities this gave him enough
power to defeat Queen and just recently
he was shown to be completely unaffected
by S shark's attacks another great cook
possibly even stronger than Sanji is
lucky Ru of the redhaired Pirates though
just like the rest of this crew his real
power is still a mystery so until more
is revealed about Rue Sanji will be the
cook of the strongest onepiece crew now
although This Crew just keeps getting
stronger and stronger no matter how
strong they get they won't be able to
survive the crazy weather of the grand
line by themselves and that's why they
need a skilled Navigator Nami would be
an obvious pick for this position as she
saved the straw hats from joh on many
many occasions also since teaming up
with Zeus she's become a formidable
fighter capable of holding her own but
even with Zeus's help it's really hard
to imagine Nami being stronger than Le
feat of the Blackbeard Pirates
admittedly we don't know much about the
guy but he has to be super strong and
also seems to have some kind of zoon
devil fruits that Grant him Wings the
only other candidate besides these two
is one of the redhair Pirates less known
officers building snake he's been on
shank crew for at least 12 years and
considering that he carries swords with
him he must also be a skilled fighter
still considering everything at this
point in the story I'm willing to bet
that lefit is the strongest Navigator in
the series so I'll have to choose him as
the navigator for our crew there are
still four roles on the ship left to
fill and next we need a skilled musician
someone who can cheer the crew up and
prepare them for hard battles ahead
scratch minipoo is an interesting
musician and he seemed like the most
capable out of all Supernova during
sality Arc the man even managed to land
a hit on kizu however once we saw more
of him I can safely say that he's the
worst Supernova as his devilred ability
can be completely countered by plugging
your years a much better choice for a
musician would be Brooke who would
surely defeat a pooh in a battle and is
also better at playing music since he's
been practicing for over 50 years while
being stranded in the floran Triangle
over the last 2 years Brook's combat
abilities have improved a lot and he
also unlocked his fruit's full potential
allowing him to infuse his sword with
his soul to give it freezing properties
another possible candidate is black
Maria who's for sure stronger than
Brooke and is also pretty skilled at
playing music but I don't think either
of these two is strong enough to be on
the crew and that's why I want to
introduce another musician the redhair
pirate senior officer Bonk punch now I
wouldn't usually put someone without any
feasts on This Crew but considering the
competition for this role is really weak
I just don't see a world in which Bonk
punch isn't the strongest musician in
the story at this point now before we
choose the Vice Captain and the captain
for This Crew we first need to answer
the most important question who will be
the crew's pet now just to clarify only
the real pets count for this role so
Chopper and beo are out since they
aren't actually pets for example camel
kuzan's Pet penguin is pretty useful
since he can never sink meaning the crew
can use him to evacuate if the ship is
ever destroyed another cool pet is Doc
Q's stronger who ate a devil fruit which
turned him into a pegasus however just
by looking at him I don't think he'd be
able to help the crew in any meaningful
way on the other hand boa's snake salom
seems useful for its ability to track
people down but then again anyone
remotely strong could just squish it in
terms of raw power and durability Kraken
or sud as Luffy named him has to be the
strongest pet there is when Kraken first
met an attacked the straw hats he was
able to survive attacks from Sanji zodo
and Luffy and when they later met up on
fishermen Island he knocked out over 100
fishmen on his own also you can't deny
how cool the crew would look with Kraken
accompanying them there's only two roles
on the crew left to fill and you'll
definitely be surprised when you see
he'll be the captain of This Crew but
before that let's choose the second most
important role the Vice Captain the Vice
Captain is most often the second
strongest person on the ship however
considering how overpowered This Crew is
already I'm not sure if that will be
possible in this situation since we're
looking for the strongest the strong
even someone like King with his flaming
lunarian blood and Powerful devil fruit
will not cut it so how about zodo the
guy who defeated King and will keep
growing by the day until he becomes the
strongest swordsman well until that
happens and he actually surpasses mihawk
I don't think he's strong enough for
this crew now It's tricky to talk about
red hair's Vice Captain Ben Beckman
because just like the rest of his crew
everything about him's a mystery the
only fight we saw him participate in was
against those Mountain Bandits on Dawn
Island and that's not all that
impressive however he does seem to hold
a big deal of of respect in the one
piece world as even kizu was pretty
cautious when Ben had a gun pointed at
his head but despite this there's
another Vice Captain who we know much
more about and who would be perfect for
This Crew the dark King rley we've seen
this guy fight on multiple occasions for
example in his prime during his fight
against Marco who's whitebeard's best
fighter reallyy was toying with him
stopping Marco's attack with a single
finger even as an old man in his 70s he
was still able to fight evenly against
Admiral kizaru and Escape unharmed even
after the time skip his hockey output
was so great it made black Black Beard
runaway no doubt in my mind Ry deserves
this spot more than any other Vice
Captain okay the crew now needs just one
more member and this final member is the
most important one the captain this is
someone who would need to command this
monstrous crew and whom everyone would
respect also keep in mind that the
captain has to be stronger than everyone
else or nobody will take him seriously
is there even a person like that well
the best place to start looking are the
four Emperors who are all monsters who
will play a role in changing the world
forever in this group we have Luffy who
time and time again breaks his limits in
order to save his friends Blackbeard who
has somehow consumed multiple devil
fruits and will crush anyone to become
the pirate king and Shanks who shrouded
in mystery and most likely the strongest
pirate Alive Now although these are all
good picks before them there was a
generation of even stronger Pirates one
of these Pirates is Whitebeard the
strongest man in the world feared by
everyone for his immense power he
clashed daily with other powerful
figures and could not be defeated even
as he grew old and sick but even
stronger than him is Roger who conquered
the Seas without any devil fruits and
became the pirate king with his
otherworldly strength and hockey however
not even these two characters are the
strongest captains in one piece because
that title goes to someone on a
completely different level the character
I'm talking about is Roxy Zeek a famous
pirate who commanded the strongest
pirate crew ever the reason I said that
he's even more powerful than Roger is
because during the god Valley incident
Roger had to team up with GARP in order
to finally bring this guy down which
just goes to show how terrifying rocks
was if there's anyone strong enough to
command this ridiculous pirate crew he
created it's got to be him ranking the
strongest Pirates is cool but did you
know that the fighters from the world
government are on a completely different
level click on this video next where we
rank all World Government fighters in
one piece